hi this is Luca from Luke Allen Pattillo
comm and today I have an announcement to
make this is about a super cool language
event that is going to take place in
Lisbon in May 2000 19 but I'm getting
ahead of myself just take a listen and
most of all take a look
[Music]
[Music]
everybody my name is Rachel paling and I
am delighted to talk to you today about
the new language learning conference
this will take place in Lisbon from the
15th to the 17th of May 2019 for the
people who know me they know that I am
absolutely passionate about how we can
enhance the learning process how can we
change education how can we help
learners to learn and how can we bring
education into the 21st century and I
have a lineup of amazing speakers who
will be contributing with various topics
ranging from coaching to neuroscience to
emotional intelligence to heart science
and they will be inspiring us they will
be helping us to develop as educators so
that we can start to really change
education and I'm delighted as well that
you know this conference will be
co-hosted with me and Luca Lampard you
know the famous polyglot who will be
co-hosting with me Luca you will with me
in Edinburgh yes and you're going to
come back and be with me in Lisbon how
do you feel about that well first of all
thank you for inviting me - Adam - I was
an amazing event and this one is going
to be even better I feel it I've been to
Lisbon before I know the event and we're
gonna have a blast
absolutely and Luca in fact will also be
speaking so what will you speak about
this time I will talk about two things
that I think they're really important
the first thing is going to be about the
ten principles of language learning and
the second one is going to be how to get
a native light pronunciation in any
language you want they may think this is
going to be hopefully very cool than you
thought absolutely you know you were one
of the favourites in Edinburgh so I'm
sure you're gonna be one of the
favorites in Lisbon as well and I feel
like a baby polyglot next to you because
I'm on my six but you're on your 14th
language learning Greek is my 14th
language Wow so I'm gonna see if I can
get some private lessons between now and
May with my Russian learning
that okay Luca it's doable this passive
yes so for more information do have a
look at the website www.levitt.com and
joiners this is going to be the most
amazing experience and I promise you
it's going to be an experience that you
will never ever forget
[Music]
so here you have it I truly hope you
like the trailer and I'm pretty sure
that if you like the trailer you're
going to love this conference last
year's conference in Scotland was
amazing with amazing speakers an amazing
venue amazing weather for that matter
and this year promises to be even better
in beautiful Lisbon if you want to know
more information check in the
description box where you're also going
to find a promo code that you can use in
order to buy a ticket for a reduced
price I'll be waiting for you and Lisbon
Rachel we'll be waiting for you in
Lisbon and we are going to have a blast